if you came face-to-face with your
younger self what would you say what
advice would you give
[Music]
okay this is wild it's like freshman
year at Duke all over again that Jackie
those Tim's that flattop and that beard
is that great this beard actually looks
pretty good yeah for an old guy
yeah well this old guy the Hall of Famer
who's on TV
every night we're on TV we're in the
Hall of Fame
did we win a title at Duke let's just
say you make coach Kay very very proud
just remember throw it's a label where
do we get drafted actually the Detroit
Pistons take us third overall the
Pistons we love the Lakers don't sweat
it
we'll eventually get to LA now in our
rookie here we get a signature shoe deal
with Fila signature shoe yep make sure
to give a pair to a rapper named Tupac
and tell them to skip the Tyson fight in
96 so what kind of a big deal
it's unbelievable people are gonna start
calling you the next Michael Jordan the
guy who won the dunk contest
just wait grant you're gonna find no one
will ever measure up to MJ on the court
not us not even LeBron Lihue he's like
six years old now ends up losing like
six NBA Finals but anyway just don't get
caught up in what people are gonna say
about you or your game there's gonna be
a mix of ups and downs look I don't have
much time left
what else um yeah remember french toast
drink sprite invest in Bitcoin and take
those cameos and home improvement and
living single hey wait I forgot to
mention Nickelback
[Music]